let us now consider a simple example let
random variables x and y be described by
a joint PMF which is the one shown in
this table question are x and y
independent we can try to answer this
question by using the definition of
independence but it is actually more
instructive to proceed in a somewhat
more intuitive way we look at this table
and we observe that the value of 1 is
possible for X in particular the
probability that X takes the value of 1
this is the marginal probability this
can be found by adding the probabilities
of all the outcomes in this column which
in this case is 3 over 20 suppose now
that somebody tells you the value of y
for example I told you that Y happens to
be equal to one in which case you are
transported into this universe in this
universe the conditional probability
that X takes a value of 1 given that Y
takes a value of 1
what is it in this universe there's 0
probability associated to this outcome
so this probability is 0 which is
different than 3 over 20 and since these
two numbers are different
this means that information from Y
changes our beliefs about what's going
to happen to X and so we do not have
independence so again intuitively in the
beginning we thought that X equal to 1
was possible but information given by Y
namely that Y is equal to 1 tells us
that actually x equals to 1 is
impossible information about Y changed
our beliefs about X so x and y are
dependent now when we first introduced
the notion of independence some time ago
we also introduced the notion of
conditional independence and we said
that conditional independence is the
same as ordinary independence except
that it would be applied to a
conditional universe something similar
can be done for the case of random
variables as well so suppose for example
that someone tells us that the outcome
of the experiment was such that it
belongs to this blue set this is the set
where X is less than or equal to 2 and Y
is larger than or equal to 3 so we are
given this information and this is now
our new conditional model the question
is within this new conditional model our
random variables x and y independent let
us write down the conditional model who
are I'm only showing the four possible
outcomes that are allowed in the
conditional model all the others of
course will have zero probability in the
conditional model so in the conditional
model probabilities will keep the same
proportions as in the unconditional
model and the proportions are 1 2 2 4
but then they need to be scaled or
normalized so that they add to 1 and to
make them add to 1 we need to divide
them all by 9 in this conditional model
this is the joint PMF
of the two random variables x and y let
us find the marginal pmfs to find the
marginal PMF of X we add the entries in
this column and we get here 1/3 and here
2/3 and to find the marginal PMF of Y we
add the entries in this column to find
2/3 and we add the entries in that
column to find 1/3 so this is the
marginal PMF of X that's the marginal
PMF of Y and now we notice that this
entry of the joint PMF is 1/3 times 1/3
the product of the marginals this entry
is the product of 1/3 times 2/3 the
product of the marginals and so on for
the remaining entries so each entry of
the joint PMF is equal to the product of
the corresponding entries of the
marginal pmfs and this is
the definition of Independence so in
this conditional blue universe we do
have independence and the way that this
was established was to check that the
joint pmf factors as a product of
marginal pmfs